hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
la entrevista de france mit y 4 en
español en esta oportunidad nos acompaña
gabriela vino esa es periodista cronista
y escritora peruana autora del libro
waco retrato allí se enfoca su mirada en
temas como por ejemplo la identidad del
racismo el colonialismo y también los
vínculos afectivos y los deseos guaco
retrató nos habla de la variedad de
formas que tiene la colonización y que
todavía nos atraviesa gabriela wiener
muchísimas gracias por tu presencia en
la entrevista de france 24
encantada de estar contigo santiago
gracias no gracias a ti una vez más
bueno elegí el uac tu retrato no estamos
hablando de esculturas precolombinas
enterradas en templos sagrados no
andinos y que representan los rostros
indígenas la protagonista que lleva a tu
mismo nombre se mira en esos huecos
exhibidos en un museo de museos europeos
y que fueron sacados de su perú natal
precisamente por sus antepasados
europeos que viste gabriela en esos
retratos y que se disparó en ti
si vi mi cara vi mi cara absolutamente
mi cara que contrastaba además con este
apellido bueno blanco europeo que es
binner siempre tuve una confusión no me
volaba la cabeza
esta especie de paradoja que es una
paradoja no sólo mía sino de muchísima
gente en américa latina' no somos un
poco los hijos de los patriarcas
europeos muchas veces dejamos atrás
despojados y abandonados y de alguna
manera me quise preguntar por ese
personaje que había sido siempre el
patriarca
de mi familia un historiador con cierto
reconocimiento que había casi estaba a
punto de llegar a machu picchu como
saben una de las maravillas del mundo
pero además tenía pues un lado bastante
oscuro no se había llevado casi 5.000
piezas estos huecos a un museo en parís
de hecho
para exponerlo en la gran exposición
universal y había sido condecorado por
por francia una de las grandes potencias
europeas a fines del siglo 19 él
realmente tuvo esta misión política
donde afianzar ese supremacismo a través
de la riqueza cultural de y el
patrimonio de un país saqueado yo creo
que debe ser la primera persona que le
llamase a creador a charles binner que
además bueno es mi presunto antepasado
tatarabuelo
si de hecho cuando una busca información
sobre ella les viniera no sé en google
en las redes encuentra que fue un
explorador no encuentran nada de
respecto de este saqueo que llevó a cabo
aquí te aquí te enfrentaste al ir
conociendo la historia de charles
bueno primero algo muy personal yo ya
soy también una migrante en españa' que
vengo del perú de una ex colonia
realmente estoy muy familiarizada ahora
mismo con la mujer en los nuevos
estadios del colonialismo para mí
enfrentar la lectura de su libro
evidentemente de un hombre de su época
pero profundamente vejatorio con mi
cultura cuando con un lenguaje racista y
además una manera de entender digamos al
otro muy actual muy muy contemporánea
desde ese lugar de es paternalista
y convirtiendo al otro en un producto de
sus proyectos de sus ansias
civilizatorias que me sonaba muy
familiar en mi contexto español él
además era alguien que se quería
blanquear era un judío migrante en
francia que se estaba convertido al
catolicismo se cambió de nombre y fue
enviado por el gobierno francés
especialmente parece de trabajo de esta
manera él se blanqueó de esta manera el
rey yo
peligros y la violencia que también por
su condición de judío a la que estaba
expuesto él de alguna manera hay un
espejo en tremendo en el que se mira la
protagonista de waco retrato porque es
este hombre y de alguna manera también
frágil que se convierte en
alguien con poder
condecorado y valioso precisamente por
saquear por dejar atrás y llevarse para
exponer no todos todas las piezas y
todos los vestigios verme digamos como
heredera de ese personaje era fuerte
para mí sobre todo en un contexto anti
racista y quise hacer una novela contar
una historia en la que el expuesto sea
él
en esas vitrinas donde se estaban
exponiendo los bajos retratos creo que
se expone también nuestra identidad
perdida que nunca fue devuelta además
miraba esos espejos en los que se ha
visto reflejada precisamente así apunta
mi próxima pregunta porque la
experiencia de la narradora es la de
vivir en los cruces no en las fronteras
donde muchos se mezclan y entre aquí por
supuesto el tema de su identidad hablas
de una cara de waco y el apellido
europeo binner que identidad se forja
abrirla en este cruce en esos espejos
tan disímiles no en los que uno se ve
reflejado bueno nos han contado siempre
que es una identidad mestiza lo mestizo
como es maría galindo la feminista
boliviana como un elemento pacificador
cuando en realidad es una memoria del
conflicto de lo que allí ocurrió es más
apropiado llamarnos bastardas o dudosas
es verdad que las personas marrones no
pueden darnos y unido generaciones atrás
sin perdernos no sin encontrar fantasmas
sin encontrar precisamente estos decesos
esa arena desenterrada o estos
estos cuerpos
de repente saqueados que han perdido
completamente su contexto de hecho una
de las cosas que también se llevó cosas
que se llevó charles binner fue un niño
indígena no esté el libro para mí es la
historia de las consecuencias de las
realidades coloniales en nuestras vidas
y en nuestro presente también yo lo
quería contar desde esa desde esa herida
abierta que que es íntima pero es
colectiva también y que hemos compartido
a lo largo de decirlos no hay una
experiencia del trauma y una experiencia
del abandono primigenio 'charles llegó
ahí ni siquiera se enteró que dejaba
toda una estirpe no y mientras él se
llevaban a un niño para probar que podía
ser educado no es desde luego es el
lugar entre los bastardo entre lo
ilegítimo entre un apellido que se sigue
generando preguntas y un antepasado que
siempre será presunto nada más se han
construido nuestras identidades y es
verdad que este es un intento de en esta
novela de disputar ese relato de
construir también una
propia a partir de esos pedazos rotos
otros temas que atraviesan muchísimo no
agua corre trato que está muy presente
entrelazados con todos estos temas de
los que nos estás hablando tiene que ver
con la sexualidad y el deseo también no
aparecen allí de una manera muy
interesante habla porque hemos planteado
una perspectiva anticolonial no del amor
del deseo de la manera de vincularnos
sexo afectivamente por llamarlo de
alguna manera verdad la mirada colonial
en américa en general crees que ha
determinado también además a quienes
amamos que cuerpos son los deseables
cuáles no
sí desde luego y no es una perspectiva
que se suele a tratar no hablamos del
género cuando hablamos del amor cuando
hablamos del cuerpo pero falta indagar
acerca de otras desigualdades y que
también condicionan completamente
nuestras relaciones la protagonista de
waco retrato se siente colonizada por el
deseo de un cuerpo blanco pero también
se vuelve quien colonizan o también la
habita el patriarcado se la posee y por
eso asiste a estos talleres de
descolonización del deseo que realmente
son unos lugares en los que se juntan de
una manera no mixta a la comunidad
racializada y antirracista buscando una
especie de reparación y de y de
encuentro en la que la gente empieza a
conversar acerca de sus propias heridas
y de haber internalizado tanto racismo
que se han despreciado a sí mismas
también se nos enseñó que debíamos amar
nuestra construcción del deseo fue
blanco y eso eso es algo que la
protagonista empieza a preguntarse y
empieza así su proceso de
descolonización que realmente no es un
proceso cerrado ni acabado sino siempre
abierto y que además de una manera
colectiva es que es que se busca de
alguna manera su sanación también y el
encuentro con la otra el encuentro con
alguien como tú
y bueno vinculado esto que decías que
abrirla ante maneras heteronormativa si
también monogámicas no de relacionarnos
la protagonista a gabriela tiene una
vida a paul ya amorosa una manera de
vincularse totalmente diferente a lo que
fue la de su padre no con dos familias
paralelas la familia heterosis no
heteronormativa agarré la es otra manera
otra más otra forma más de colonialismo
bueno y ella desde luego se empezó a
construir su familia y sus relaciones
para no reproducir la historia de su
padre el padre de la protagonista es un
padre que tiene una doble vida que ha
tenido una manera patriarcal de
relacionarse con su pareja con sus
parejas con sus hijas que es una cosa
muy habitual por cierto en nuestros
hogares siempre aparecen estos hijos
ilegítimos por todos lados las otras
mujeres que viven en unas condiciones de
marginalidad y ella no quiere eso ella
quiere realmente asumirse y confrontar
de una manera que encuentran o de alguna
manera encuentra en la no monogamia ese
lugar pero también siente que allí no en
esa cosa tan
normal del poliamor y sus reglamentos y
sus acuerdos hay una parte que está
oprimida que es parte de su identidad su
latinidad su manera de sentir el amor de
sentir los celos de sentir su sexualidad
y que la vulnerabilidad o también porque
es precisamente eso es lo que no estamos
teniendo en cuenta que llegamos a
nuestras relaciones habiendo soportado
muchas violencias y patriarcales pero
también violencias racistas
de nuestros cuerpos y eso nos pone en
una situación de desigualdad no podemos
ser todas tan libres y tan polis
amorosas con las mochilas y las heridas
que vamos cargando en nuestra vida es
por eso que ella de repente empieza
también a cuestionar su propia condición
de paul y amorosa y encuentra más bien
en su comunidad antirracista muchísima
más afinidad y comprensión de su
vulnerabilidad de sus celos es una
manera de justificarse también pero una
manera de encontrarse a sí misma y de
relacionarse de otra manera hay quizás
también no sé opresión eso también
corsets por llamarlo de alguna manera
fuera del amor romántico no y dentro de
estas nuevas maneras de vincularse
sí desde luego que sí bueno para que
nuestros cuerpos marrones y racializados
es muy importante hacer esta ruptura con
la cuestión tan estructurada no tan
racional de ciertas de cierta manera de
amar aunque ésta sea una forma de amar
libre pero si del todo occidental nos
buscamos en lo comunitario quizá y
también en la comprensión por ejemplo de
nuestros pasados en nuestras memorias de
dónde venimos precisamente lo que busca
este libro también que se escarbar un
poco en ese pasado en esa historia
patriarcal desde un antepasado desde un
padre no desde desde tantos fantasmas
que nos han rodeado para poder entender
nuestro presente y cómo estamos amando y
como somos amadas también esto es la
familia
normativa también es algo a descolonizar
no no en el sentido de pensar que
debemos bloquear otro tipo de una
familia más tradicional o monógama sino
en el sentido de decir que nuestras
familias no deben ser en nuestra familia
diversas no deben ser perseguidos
deben ser acosados ni discriminados sino
que tengan su derecho a existir en este
mundo y ha resistido de esa manera
gabriela wiener muchísimas gracias por
este diálogo con france24 ha sido muy
interesante charlar contigo hoy a ti y
santiago te mando un abrazo muchas
gracias otro para ti y a nuestra
audiencia como siempre le invitamos a
que sigan informando se en el resto de
nuestra programación y también por
supuesto en france mit y cuatro.com
sigan con nosotros